you know where this progressive faith
really exposes itself in this gender
issue
a woman just went viral on tick-tock
because her six-year-old daughter
said that she thinks she looks like a
boy are you a boy are you a girl
[Music]
[Music]
what makes you think that
[Music]
mommy can i get this
so the caption here is my six-year-old
daughter asks me if i think she looks
like a boy i asked her do you want to
look like a boy
her response left me speechless
does it count if yeah okay that's fine
it's available now for pre-order by the
way my upcoming book
the subtitle is controlling words
controlling minds
this woman has left me somewhat
speechless
i'll regain my speech and then give my
thoughts on her
this constitutes child abuse but this
woman might not even know what she's
doing
she might really buy into this idea that
little children
have the ability to freely consent to
major sexual decisions which is
preposterous but you might have the idea
that little children know more about
reality than adults do
maybe they know more than this adult
woman does and she she might really
believe that our who we really are has
nothing to do with our physical bodies
but that is wrong that's a different
religion that is a big
fat lie and as long as we've got
republicans
who have all their guns there are all
their rhetorical guns trained on other
republicans
defending these absolutely absurd lies
on the left much bigger lies than
anything the right's been telling
then those people are no use to the
conservative
movement hey don't go anywhere
because youtube will tell you sometimes
that
you know you'll get notifications for my
show well you know what i call that i
call that a big lie
you need to make sure that you ring the
bell that you like that you subscribe
and then you will have a slightly better
chance of getting notifications when we
get new videos out see you then